les noms de communes insolite font-ils
baisser les prix du mètre carré
autrement dit si votre maison se situe à
très con dans la marne à anus dans
l'yonne ou encore à glandage dans la
drôme voter le moins cher que dans le
village voisin c'est le figaro qui s'est
posé cette question et qui est allé
interroger les agents immobiliers dans
plusieurs petites communes aux noms
cocasses et a priori la réponse est non
c'est une bombe lancée par benjamin
castaldi vendredi dernier on va aller
jusqu'à 10 dose de rappel le
gouvernement qui prévoirait jusqu'à 10
dose de rappel soit une dose de vaccin
tous les trois mois une nouvelle qui n'a
pas l'air de réjouir les français et
surtout le rappeur booba et moi j'ai une
autre info qui est extra confidentiel
mais je vous la révèle aujourd'hui en
exclusivité et cette info c'est qu'on
l'a dans le cul
les noms insolites ne font pas baisser
que ce soit fourre tout dans l'aude ou
bien à la trique dans les deux sèvres
les agents immobiliers explique que le
nom de la commune fait sourire les
nouveaux arrivants facilite parfois la
prise de contact mais ne fait pas
baisser le prix de sa criticité un lien
je pensais qu'ils annoncent la
discussion ça va même faire la montée a
pris comme à montcuq dans le lot rendu
célèbre par daniel prévost avec son
reportage le petit rapporteur dans les
années 70 depuis la renommée attire
toujours autant de curieux dans mon cul
et les 8
hors de l'eau sur la lune
les bidets c'est le business
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'avais mal réglé mon bébé
c'est bizarre d'un coup je me sens
beaucoup plus frais aux alentours de 6
heures du matin environ la lune la terre
et le soleil étaient alignés pour nous
offrir une éclipse totale visible à
l'oeil nu sans danger les plus matinaux
donc pu voir l'une rouge parce que les
rayons du soleil sont filtrées il n'y a
que la lumière rouge qui en ressort
c'est un peu comme un lever ou un
coucher de soleil c'était un très beau
spectacle en tout cas mais castanet
voulait n'importe quoi un document sur
notre logiciel
sous la source castaldi d'un chasseur à
la différence de quoi j'ai fait une
enquête j'ai été contacté
[Applaudissements]
est ce que dans votre champ bien en ce
moment je fais de l'herbe ah d'accord
tu pourrais vous en avoir un petit peu
c'est le genre de truc on essaie
tard que jamais
comme on dit
ça fait bizarre c'est bizarre
[Musique]
genre faits réels la voir entrer c'est
vrai que petites canettes d'un mètre
soixante a qu'un grand sourire tous
c'est petit hamster c'est assez marrant
baisse de mon corps rebelle mois et
baissent donne mans 1 2 t puis savoureux
d'ornement un de tes plus amoureux je te
rendrai 4 plus chaud que breizh c'est
pour rappeler aux plus jeunes et aussi à
laurent que baiser ça se fait en
mélangeant les dents tu as des super
longs cils
original
[Rires]
confectionnant
tout tu as
tu peu trop doux
que bouffer des crocs par petits bouts
un jour ouais je te mettre devant je
fais bouffer les conseillers si j'ai
tort à petit le même gars quand on va
chez lui pour bosser le midi il ouvre
une bouteille de rosé picoler
complètement
m
[Applaudissements]
les théories sur les îlots de gaza
niçois jean
bataille ouais je suis regardé les
élèves toilettes à stopper
je te regarde on va
passer
une canette
taito